well that's probably the nicest
introduction I've ever had thank you
I'm actually really experiencing a
little bit of nostalgia because I've
taken classes in this room I've sat in
those seats looking this direction and I
also have two of my mentors in the room
James Landay and Terry Winograd who I
can confidently say if I didn't know
them and they hadn't played a large part
in my life I would not be standing here
so it's really special for me it's also
special to the point that I put on the
last shirt I ever bought as a Stanford
student which was in the late 90s well
2000 actually right on the number or so
it's somehow shrunk over the last 19
years I must be the humidity in Seattle
don't tell anyone at u-dub I didn't wear
a u dub pls okay so today I want to talk
about addressing situationally induced
impairments and disabilities in mobile
HCI no texting while biking those signs
that's a real thing that's a real sign I
didn't make that computing environments
have changed drastically in the last
many decades when you when we were
computing interacting with a computer
system in say the 80s and I'm old enough
to actually have done that the the
assumptions about the environment we we
were in are very different than the
assumptions we make today we could
assume we were in a stable temperature
maybe an office environment things
aren't moving
there's minimum distractions light
levels are pretty steady generally it's
a fairly you know state environment
today like the picture shows we might
interact on a beach even with a laptop
which is still awfully close to the
desktop machine on the left in so many
ways and yet sitting on the beach with
sunlight glare it looks maybe like it's
a cold weather beach given the Hat and
so on so it's maybe not very warm the
hands might be cold the fingers are
stiff and you know the posture is
entirely different there's no chair
involved all of those changes and so
that's just one example but if we go
even further to smart phones and things
think about all the ways that we
interact both discretion at our
discretion you know just for enjoyment
with your own
personal phone but also increasingly
many jobs many roles in the workplace
are out of the office and in the field
and there's a cost to this so we have
cognitive perceptual and motor cost
probably others too like social costs
you know hello it's great to see you and
we're distracted and don't notice and
then we make people sad so it's
important to recognize that this doesn't
come for free this this flexibility of
environments how many times have you you
know been trying to get on or off a bus
and someone doesn't notice you're trying
to move past them because they're glued
to their phone right or you've been that
person and it's not about making
ourselves feel bad but it is a
recognition that this comes at a cost
because our attention is so limited and
studies have confirmed this so we know
that we have reduced you know reading
speed reduced motor accuracy actually we
tend to look at our screens in a way
again with a smartphone when we're
moving at every four seconds so that's a
very short burst of interactive time and
we can't avoid obstacles as easily and
so on so have we been coping when I say
we I mean kind of society like the world
the developed world at least have we
been coping with these types of
challenges well here's one way heads-up
cross the street and then update
Facebook this is a real sign from
Hayward California and the state we're
in further afield Stockholm Sweden
decided they were tired of trying to
notify the textures to wait and so they
started notifying the drivers not to hit
them so beware of the drivers yield to
the texter who's not paying attention in
Utah you can get a distracted walking
fine now
which includes texting it's a $50 fine
the first time in $100 the second time
that's not I think statewide I think
it's Salt Lake Honolulu was in the news
last October because they passed a law
that if you're caught texting while
caught in the crosswalk so you're in the
crosswalk which you know that's where
you should be right you're not
jaywalking but if you're texting while
doing so you can be slapped too fine
right on the spot this is the over in
China they experimented with two
different lanes cellphones if you want
to walk with your cell phone go over
here it's
your own risk or you know the
cellphone-free lane
turns out this this as a social
experiment failed because people were so
enamored by the instructions they would
actually crowd the cellphone line
reading the instructions and kind of oh
look at this and then people would run
into them actually there's a whole
neighborhood in London that put padded
lampposts around because people were
were running into lampposts so notice
what we're doing here we're actually
changing the environment to accommodate
behavior that is based on our
interaction with these devices that
consume us in Amsterdam they said well
you're already looking down at some in
some fashion so maybe we should actually
be putting the signals on the ground
that's kind of clever a nice design idea
it's kind of an elegant image I like
that one the the US Federal
Communications Commission estimates that
at any one daylight moment in the United
States six hundred sixty thousand people
are texting while driving if you kind of
divide that out and start portioning it
out by cities and geography that means
someone near you don't do that and it
doesn't just have to be you know driving
could be on bikes bicycles right I don't
know what this is all about exactly
although there was an article attached
to it which said that this person wanted
to show that they could stand on their
motorcycle and send a text while riding
backwards but notice also they had to
remove the glove from their hand so
there was a clothing encumbrance there
as well
we'll break some of those down later
these folks went really to an extreme
and this is getting a little absurd but
that's why it's it's funny they actually
jumped out of an airplane and used their
company's software on a tablet to build
a website from start to finish before
they hit the ground so they said it's so
easy to use you can be this
situationally constrained and you'll
still be able to build a website that
fast I don't know how high they were
maybe they went really high so they had
more time but we don't have to get that
ridiculous so how many of you have owned
gloves that specifically have the
capacitive sensing fingertips and yet
you still take off your glove to
interact with exhibit exhibit one do you
take these off when you actually need
like on the bus or do you leave mana
yeah yeah I mean that some work better
than others and they're you know they're
improving but it's it's not suddenly the
the magic bullet usually so the point of
all this is that we interact in ways
that constrain us that affect our
abilities the environments exert a lot
of pressure on us and our attention is
diverted in ways that make that that
challenging and there's lots of ways
that this can happen and our ability
state interact are compromised and then
we go and adapt ourselves but the point
I want to leave you with from this is
think how little the computer and I say
computer meaning very broadly the
smartphone laptop whatever think how
little it actually knows about where you
are and what you're doing it'll it knows
almost nothing did you know that sure it
GPS wise it kind of knows a Latin
longitude but that's not really your
context right
it just doesn't know they're pretty
oblivious and we have a long history of
adapting ourselves to a rigid world and
and we see that very prominently in
assistive technology so these are images
in the post-world War 2 era the belief
was that the environment is static
disability exists within the person so
if you've lost a leg we're going to give
you a replacement so that you can now
adapt back to the environment all right
we're going to make you what you we're
going to restore you to what you had
before perhaps and this is this is kind
of an old image set of images but we
still have have this adaptation today
here are images of people working with
devices that don't have any idea that in
this case there's a motor limitation the
image up in the top that person has no
arms so they're actually learn to type
with their feet and some other you know
using a trackball with your chin some of
these images are actually from my
studies and again the devices don't know
the computer systems don't know so is
this really accessible computing or is
it actually evidence
adaptable humanity right humans are
incredibly adaptable that's why we're
still here for now and so I would submit
that these kinds of things are less
about accessible computing and more
about adaptable humans so it's it's
because of that intersection that people
in accessible computing have realized
and kind of tied a link to say the
environment can actually impair you the
environment the situation can disable
you Andrew Sears was the first to put
some language to this with these exact
terms but as I'll show you in a moment
it's it's been thought about for a while
he says both the environment in which
individuals are working and their
current activities so what they're doing
what they're trying to do can contribute
to the existence of impairments
disabilities and handicaps well that's
kind of interesting because that means
any of us could be disabled depending on
the environment and the activity okay
well we'll come back to that because
maybe that takes something away from
other kinds of disabilities but let's go
with that for now now this might seem
it's some level obvious like well sure
of course the environment especially
after all the images I've shown you the
environment clearly can cause you to be
impaired in some way or disabled maybe
in some way but it wasn't always thought
about that way as I said as I said with
those images of the assistive technology
after World War two disability
originally by the World Health
Organization when it was finally
formalized in the definition was defined
as any restriction or lack of ability to
perform an activity in the manner or
within the range considered normal for a
human being it's from the 70s it's
obviously very normative language you
know what's what's normal it's kind of
like the myth of the average person
everybody's different individual
differences are the only normal thing
fortunately this is deprecated and and
and we no longer place a disability just
within the person it's not just inside
you and only there in fact there's a
complex model but I'll point out that
environmental factors are now called out
as well as the activity and other
we haven't lost body functions and
structure but there's more at work here
that contribute to a notion of
disability it's a more complex phenomena
it's not just within the person so
disability as a product of the
environment has been recognized for some
time in the accessibility community so
when I show you this image and I say
where's the disability what do you first
think if you're honest well there's a
guy in a wheelchair right well yeah
that's not untrue but it's not really
the whole story the disability it's a
little blurry on the big screen but the
disability also is because there's a set
of stairs there and presumably given his
orientation maybe he wants to go up the
stairs or wishes he could be at the top
that would be the goal but the
disability therefore lies not just
within him but also within the
environment because if that was a smooth
ramp he would not be experiencing a
disability in that moment so clearly in
a simple example like that we see the
environment plays a big role now I do
have a little bit of text I try not to
make slides with too much text but
there's some quotes I want to read you
before we go on to some projects that
we've done to address these things and
they're they're kind of early
foundational quotes Alan F Newell also
was a high social impact Award winner
years ago and he observed a very similar
thing without the language of
situational impairments but a similar
thing way back in 1995 he said a soldier
on a battlefield can be blinded by smoke
deafened by gunfire mobility impaired by
being up to the waist in mud have poor
tactile sensitivity and dexterity
because of wearing a chemical warfare
suit and be cognitively impaired because
of being scared stiff of being killed
and this is before the soldier is
wounded if one were to measure the
effective abilities of a person in such
an environment they would be poor enough
over a number of dimensions for him or
her to be classified as severely
disabled in a more normal environment
and he had this picture in his black and
white you know hand-drawn textbook kind
of a classic image if you like something
a little more recent this is Newsweek's
shot in Afghanistan not too long ago
think about the abilities of these
otherwise very abled presumably abled
soldiers Gregg Vanderheiden also a
social impact Award winner a little
pattern here I suppose these people have
been really foundational and in this
thinking he talks about how
accessibility benefits everyone and
that's a that's a message we like to say
but then it's often not kind of fully
lived out usually people go as far as
the curb cuts example if we have a curb
cut then it helps a ten-speed bike list
bicyclists and a person in a wheelchair
and a person pushing a baby stroller
well that's true and then it kind of
stops but how do we think more broadly
about how accessibility can benefit
anyone if it's true we could all be
impaired or disabled by situation and
context as we interact then it seems
just to hold that that in fact this
could be for all of us if we design
systems which are truly ubiquitous and
nomadic that we can use whether we are
walking down the hall driving the car
sitting at our workstation or sitting in
a meeting that we can use when we're
under stress or distracted and that make
it easy for us to locate and use new
services we will have created systems
which are accessible to almost anyone
with a physical or sensory disability
different environments will put
constraints on the type of physical and
sensory input and output techniques that
will work most all of the issues around
providing access to people with
disabilities will be addressed if we
simply address the issues raised by this
range of environments so that is a kind
of an agenda setting idea that we pursue
these kinds of systems that allow
everyone to have better access now I
want to highlight something that I
touched on earlier but I wanted to come
back to there is not a claim here and
I'm certainly not making it that
situationally or environmentally induced
impairments and disabilities are somehow
the same as physical or functional
disabilities they're not the same so for
example a woman trying to interact
one-handed with a laptop while on the
phone holding a baby clearly has a lot
going on there is not experiencing the
same one-handed life experience as a
one-handed individual this I like this
photo because although this person has
one arm clearly he's very able that's a
strong individual very fit strong
individual so we're not saying these are
the same kinds of things
there's a different lived experience
there's not stigma attached to that top
image there's no culture of disability
there's no need for legal or policy
protections in that upper case but there
are real impairing effects there and the
key point for design is that a design
that benefits a laptop design for
example that benefits that woman in that
situation might also well benefit a
one-armed individual and so if we think
about design for all we can think about
how we can benefit both there are lots
of potential sources of situationally
induced impairments and disabilities
I've listed a handful here but I won't
read them all but you can see it's not
just physical or kind of motor
disabilities it's attention it's stress
fatigue intoxication I'll show you a
project actually at the end about
detecting intoxication rain water can
impede your ability to interact and so
forth we can actually get a head around
this space rather than just having like
a big long list like this if we think
about two dimensions one is location
does the source of the impairment come
from outside the self or inside the self
and it's not just a binary I think
there's a bit of a spectrum here where
there's kind of a mixed middle place so
photosensitive epilepsy for example is
both from the light source and it's
pattern and and the condition within the
person but I could also take someone I
could take the most fit active you know
Michael Jordan the basketball star and
put him in a straitjacket and although
he's very able otherwise he's not able
to do much right so that's good tirely
from without himself on the other axis
we can think about the duration are they
kind of ephemeral as soon as I sat down
the baby or the groceries I'm no longer
losing the lack of use of my arm to more
enduring or even permanent and we can
then make a space right we like to make
2d spaces I do at least and we can put a
whole lot of things on it which I won't
read but they're a bunch of things we
could address that would enable us to
interact better in these environments in
these situations most of conventional
assistive technology and accessible
computing has been just in this far
bottom right corner and there's a whole
lot else going on here if you want to
see more and that including that diagram
the communications of the ACM from last
June there's your own former president
and faculty member had an article of
mine with some colleagues called ability
based design where all these ideas are
kind of laid out and put together so let
me ask you a few questions what if what
if our devices were more aware of our
situated abilities not just our
abilities but in our situations
what if sorry what if if they were how
can how could we make them so and then
what could we do with that all right so
there's kind of a what how and and then
you know what good is it so I'm gonna to
or some projects not all of these but
over the last 10 years or so along with
many other research streams that we've
done we have pursued kind of here and
there different projects that fall into
this space of improving our ability to
interact under situational impairments
walking user interfaces walk type grip
sense context types which bag drunk user
interfaces that's a fun one and rain
check and I'll talk about four and I'm
going to go through them at a higher
level than I would if they were each
their own
you know conference paper or journal
paper but they all have been but I don't
have time to give that level of detail
but you can look them up very easily
just by their name here and and find the
details in the paper but let me give you
kind of a flyover because I want to show
you what's possible and one of the
driving forces behind these projects is
to not add additional sensors to phones
use the onboard commercial stuff with no
extra custom stuff because if we do that
well that's also an interesting way to
go we limit our ability to deploy I do
want to give credit where credit is due
I've worked on the projects I'm going to
talk about mainly with these folks mind
well Alex Maria caucus and Shweta Patel
Maya is a professor at Carnegie Mellon
now having started I think a year or two
ago alex is on the job market currently
he did apply to Stanford you should
interview him he's very good
I hope you'll I hope I will do him
justice here if it's not good it's my
fault if it's great it's his it's his
credit and Shrek Mattel's the MacArthur
Genius award winner who at least the
faculty in the room probably have heard
of and you're meant to interview Alex
not sweat 'ok we like having him at
u-dub so you interview Alex just to be
clear all right let's start with walk
type so the challenge here was and this
was back before the most advanced soft
key boards were out this was back in the
work was mainly in 2010 and 11 and the
challenge was was typing on a soft
keyboard and it's still the case
somewhat although they've gotten much
better but typing on a soft keyboard was
fairly inaccurate especially if you're
actually walking I would argue in fact
that most of our phones are really
portable devices but I don't know if
they're actually mobile in the sense
that you're using them while moving you
know are they mobile I don't know we
could debate that but they certainly
were less mobile then and this image
shows red key presses or errors and
green ones are correct strikes in this
particular image and and we can do this
with it so we can actually through some
pretty basic machine learning class
reclassify these key presses while
you're walking to make them much more
accurate in fact we can reduce errors by
about half which is in text Gentry
research if you can cut errors by five
percent you've done something really
well and so half is a huge win well
let's go through this a little bit more
so we train you know we captured
training data kind of a familiar
pipeline here of how these projects go
we had 16 participants they were sitting
and they were walking in walking we had
to control that so that we had a human
pace setter that led them at a pace they
entered 50 phrases each they did type
with just two thumbs so we were
restricting to that posture in this case
but there's no reason this wouldn't
generalize to other postures we
collected almost 50,000 key presses so
there's a fair bit of low-level data
here we also collected three axis
accelerometer data and touch events so
up down travel duration and so on and we
built some models so the sim
this first model we built we call the
key bounce model which is simply just a
baseline model of if you're in the the
key boundary it's a hit and if you're
off it's a Miss and we know that because
we've issued that sentences they're
typing and we can figure out the
character level error rates and even
just with touch down the baseline here
gives us a 72% 10-fold cross-validation
classification accuracy okay now let's
do something more interesting but that's
kind of what we're comparing to right
that's sort of the most basic if we add
other those other touch events to the
model we also noticed that people when
hitting the phone
we looked at some high-res video in slow
motion the key presses make the phone go
up and down in the z-axis quite a lot so
we suspected that might matter a great
deal and then we also thought well
general motion of the phone is also
something to capture so let's capture
acceleration in all three axes and so we
grab more touch events you can see those
there we grab the vertical direction at
each tap when a tap happens we also
double integrate to get the vertical
displacement of the phone and then we
also get the acceleration between
successive tabs we resample that to get
some finer data points within it and
that gives us the overall vibration
essentially of the phone and that brings
us to ninety four point six percent in
our accuracy which seems better
obviously if we take out the
acceleration features and just do the
touch features just in case you're
curious touch only would bring us those
other touch events bring us to 90 okay
now here's the fun part actually we
could figure out which foots hit in the
ground and we could we didn't believe we
could do that but we we figured out we
could it was kind of a surprise to us to
the idea was that if we look at the
x-axis which is the side motion there's
a systemic inward rotation of the device
just enough as you step I'm exaggerating
that we could detect that and it causes
an inward rotation of the of the
corresponding thumb so people are
systematically slightly inside their
intended
target and because of that we can
develop a phase of gait model where we
know which foot is moving forward at
each tap if you're above the mean line
essentially it's the right foot if
you're below the the moving mean it's
the left and when then we also know the
x-axis you know information as well so
when we combine all that together we
actually go up a little bit more as well
that's just kind of fun to think that
you could actually tell which foot is
moving forward so the final walk type
model worked as follows there's a
concept we did not come up with it's a
simple one but it's important called
touch anchors you you have a space at
the center of the key where you just
declare they must have meant this key
because they're so dead in the middle
and it was about 20% of the key width in
and I think in X and 50% in Y but if
they miss the touch anchor which happens
a lot then majority rules from the three
models you just saw if they all disagree
the walking pattern model wins because
it was the most accurate and our final
classification accuracy with this
approach was 97.3% which allows us to
correct a lot of those misses but then
we have to evaluate it right we're not
just doing the offline evaluation so in
an interactive study where participants
were blinded to whether or not they were
using the walk type or the regular
keyboard they were sitting and walking
there were sixteen of them they entered
thirty phrases each about sixty thousand
key presses and we see that with sitting
there's no significant difference in
their words per minute for entry speed
but while walking they were actually
about 13% faster that's nice we were
mostly focused on accuracy but if you're
more accurate you're also probably going
to be a little faster because there's
less error correction and that's where
we see with sitting there was a
reduction in error rate that's fairly
considerable but it's almost 50% with
walking so we seem to have one of those
nice results where we're not hurting
anything and we're only helping if
anything at all also 14 out of 16
participants when asked which of the two
conditions which they didn't know
because there's no visual difference
they preferred 14 and 16 preferred walk
type
turned out so that's kind of nice if you
type situational impairments into google
scholar walk types the first paper to
come up so it's easy to find and kind of
fun for us to see that it's become
associated with that ya know because you
could add you could add language models
and stuff on top of these keyboards till
the cows come home and modern keyboards
now do much more of that than back then
but that would actually just make it
harder to see the difference from the
touch based stuff so we wanted to keep
those concerns out right I'm not sure I
don't know we'll take it though I might
have known then it might mean you're
still yeah you're still moving while
sitting I mean not as much right but
you're still moving so there's still the
z-axis pressure and so on it's like one
more than I want to keep moving so we
get through the other ones right much
more recently yeah so was not like the
deep speech to engine we used we being
James and I and others used in our
recent paper that I think you're
referring to voice has so voice has
certainly a place in the scope of
solving situational impairments but it
is certainly not the silver bullet
because of all sorts of other factors
like privacy social issues ambient noise
I mean they're just kind of apples and
oranges so I don't think I'm certainly
not and and we've never claimed for
example that voice kind of means the
soft keyboard on a smartphone is dead
right and and actually clearly it's not
in fact right now some people are
texting but they're not speaking this is
a good example of where it wouldn't be
appropriate so I think it's a bull a
bull thing you know
okay go through grip sense quickly here
watching the time a little bit so this
project was about trying to understand
just having a device know just this
which is how are you holding it just
that much context about the user right
are you holding in your right or left
hand two-handed or interacting with an
index finger because you're holding it
in an offhand also this for zooming in
and out stinks this is the one-handed
version of pinch-to-zoom we've all done
it but it's no good right why have you
done it because your other hand or arm
was busy or you were holding you know
you were holding on on the bus so you
don't fall over or whatever so at there
are times when we've all done that I
know you haven't asked for hands but
that's not a good experience that's
usually quite inaccurate and so on so
could we actually enable a one-handed
zoom with one finger based on pressure
without a pressure sensing screen and
the answer is yes and I'll just preview
what we did we we actually pull some as
often happens with some vibrotactile
feedback we pulse the vibration motor
when you press on the screen in an app
where that would be relevant and if
you're pressing lightly it zooms out if
you're pressing hard it zooms in
actually feels pretty good and we can
tell because the gyroscope signal is
dampened when you're pressing harder so
your pressure dampens the signal and so
we know you're pressing hard so it's
kind of a straight door since use this
that's I won't play the whole video but
let's take a look for a moment here to
infer users postures like whether the
device is on a flat surface or being
handled with an index finger or left or
right thumb it can also sense the amount
of pressure or user exerts on the
touchscreen without adding any new
sensors to the device those handles
their devices in a number of grips
encryptions combines a number of
phenomena to detect hand posture because
of the shape and position of the thumb
users often draw an arc when using their
thumbs these arcs have distinctly
different shapes for both thumbs
however while using index finger there
is no such arc
shape and position of the thumb also
leads to different touch sizes when we
touch different areas of the screen in
different grips the touch size on the
same side as a pump will be smaller than
the touch size on the far side combining
these phenomena together leads to a
robust grip detection so you can see
there's a little delay between when it
updates in Poe switch hands and it'll
stay running takes about five energy
mean steps phospholipid absolute even
completes two words while typing the
grip sense uses a normal combination of
gyroscope and vibration motor to infer
pressure applied on the screen we
trigger the vibration motor when a user
touches the screen here on the right you
can see the pressure values derived from
a pressure sensor and on the left you
can see the vibration information of the
device it is evident that the vibration
of the device decreases with increase in
pressure while using devices with one
hand users often feel the need for a
robust and intuitive alternate input
method here users zoom in to a map by
pressing hard and light touch helps the
user zoom out this can be useful in a
number of postures and situations here
absence is used on a table to toggle
between lower and upper case the user
presses hard to enter uppercase letters
whereas less pressure is used to enter
lowercase letters using similar
techniques of pressure detection grips
ins also enforce pressure exerted on the
body of the device okay we'll stop there
so essentially we're leveraging features
from the motion of the swipes and tap
size essentially and also the in the
case of pressure the the dampening of a
gyroscope signal so in a evaluation of
both of these capabilities with grip
detection we saw that with about five
taps if we limited it only to tapping
like on a on a keyboard for example we
we could be about 84% accurate with
which hand is gripping the device if we
allow sin to that we can bring that down
to 2.4 interactions and increase the
accuracy because swipes gives so much
more signal and we're where do
that's based on like you saw the
rotation of the device which is from the
gyroscope the touch size and the shape
of the swipe arcs in the case where
we're using those for pressure detection
if we want three levels of pressure
distinction this is through a decision
tree then we can do about 95% accurate
if we only want to we can go up to about
almost ninety eight and we're also here
using the gyroscope as as you saw in the
video
touch size in the touch location so
relatively simple models but they can
give information to the phone that it
normally doesn't have all make sure to
finish with some time for questions so
you can ask them then switch back
changes things from the input side to
the output side so can we make the
device a bit more aware of of your
attention such that when you return it
to the device after looking away it can
aid you in task resumption so it's
affecting the output of the display so
as I mentioned before results show that
there's about a four second burst of
interaction if your mobile with your
phone you're not generally attending to
the screen longer than that of course
that's somewhat dependent on how crowded
things are and how risky they are and
all the rest but that's a reasonable
average the point is it's a small number
small amount of time and with switchback
we applied it to reading because how
many of you have the experience where
you've read even in a just an old paper
book you've read the page you look away
and you look back and you start way
above where you left off I never started
below where I left off
anyone ever start further than they
thought not so much you maybe yeah
you're living in your own future but
usually we kind of go to the top of the
page or some some maybe landmark I'm not
quite sure what the phenomena is there
at work cognitively but what we wanted
is people can read and then so they're
you know reading down the lines and then
as they look away and we know they will
when they look back at the screen we do
some highlighting and we get inspiration
here from patrick Bowdish as phosphor
desktop highlighting were
and and other things like that and kind
of help them resume mobile devices are
often used in environments that
constantly change forcing the user to
break focus and attend to their
environment
we introduced switchback a system that
facilitates task resumption for mobile
devices switchback is built upon our
focus and saccade tracking which uses
the mobile devices front-facing camera
in two ways
saccade tracking observes the user's
gaze as it jumps to different parts of
the screen here we show saccade tracking
being used in the context of reading
every large gaze jump across the screen
corresponds to a new line being read if
these are becomes distracted he risks
forgetting where he last read with
switch back however the system can
highlight where the user had stopped
focus tracking monitors the users
attention as the user walks off the bus
he must look away from his device once
the user returns his focus to the screen
switch back and draw his attention to
where he left off so you might think oh
just point the camera the front-facing
camera at the face and the eyes tracked
them and you can see the pixel they're
looking at it it's that doesn't work
it's much harder than that it turns out
you can't get that level of resolution
and accuracy but you can do well enough
to track like we are the eye movements
in their saccade and generally the face
at the screen and and not and so on and
so you know and that will improve over
time and maybe eventually we'll have
true eye tracking from a front-facing
camera but we don't have that really yet
so we first check and see if they're
looking at the the camera or looking at
the device rather and where the pupil is
these are fairly conventional computer
vision techniques and then as you saw in
the video we can actually track the
movement of the eyes well enough to know
where the secod happen the secod czar
the jumps from the end of one line to
the next
and so then knowing that we can do some
basic things like smooth the signal find
peaks and valleys and then infer the
cicadas and therefore the
red so this is mapped right now to
reading but that's where we found it's
actually particularly problematic
because you've got a high-resolution set
of lines to read like a New York Times
article or something and they're looking
away and it's hard to kind of resume we
did evaluate this in a in a controlled
experiment I'll quickly mention so we
had a reading task with 17 participants
and they they went through a two by two
by two within subjects design with these
three factors of two levels each so they
were standing versus walking a
distraction task that we took from
psychology versus not having that and
then a control condition where they
didn't have switched back and switched
back they were their reading speed was
validated with a comprehension test to
make sure they actually did read it so
the phone is here they're on a treadmill
so there's that laboratory aspect to
this but the phone is there and then the
distraction tasks for that condition
does appear there which essentially asks
them to count the number of ELLs in a
field of tees which is not that easy and
takes a few seconds so it forces them to
look away and and then by doing so we
can see how they resume and what we see
for reading speed here on the left side
without the distraction tasks there's no
difference so that's good we're not
doing harm but when there is a
distraction task we're getting about an
8% win in reading speed it's not massive
but it's it was statistically
significant and more to the point you
know we're seeing that there's some
benefit here it's about 20 words a
minute faster that'd be great on a entry
side on the reading side it's a little
bit of a less less percentage but it's
still still a nice outcome and then the
last one I want to touch on before I
wrap and take some questions is Dewey's
instead of gooeys these are Dewey's
drunk user interfaces what are drunk
user interfaces so the idea was can we
actually estimate the blood-alcohol
level of a person using a smartphone
straight out to be a very popular study
among the students 21 and older at the
University we got lots of people to sign
up for this because we got them drunk
over the course of an entire
a week and this is all totally approved
by the IRB we that was not I just want
to make sure that's on the video but we
actually had them go from a completely
sober condition all the way up to the
legal limit we did not push them beyond
that for ethical reasons just so you
know point o4 is what the national
health standards say is the decision
boundary between if you're beyond that
you're drunk and if you're or you're
you're not sober I should say and below
that you're still considered legally
sober and and so we developed some tasks
which we call drunk user interfaces that
help us model the change in human
performance when you're under the
influence now why would you want to do
this on a smartphone and we're not
reading blood levels right we're not
pricking people they're not pricking
themselves with their phone we're not
it's not a direct reading well you know
people might want to prevent drunk
driving and maybe their car insurance
says you know you get this app and you
use it after 10:00 p.m. but if you're
gonna drive and we'll give you a
discount or maybe this is the best use
case on campuses drunk texting
perfection oMG I love you oMG you're
drunk go home how is me saying I love
you a sign of me being drunk it's not
the OMG is that's funny
barely you don't as much that's okay
informal assessment situations do happen
so bartenders sometimes want to verify
or or know if someone's maybe had too
much or maybe you want to do that for
yourself so self-awareness education
things like that so these are the five
tasks that after exploring a whole range
of human performance tasks and other
types we we came to typing swiping
combined balance and heartrate tasks
it's hand balancing not the whole body
simple reaction time and choice reaction
time so some of these are very old
psychology tasks in text entry they
enter some phrases there are a lot of
different features we could pull off
this one is called utilized bandwidth
this is a text entry measure but it
amounts to basically how many of the
characters you strike are useful in the
phrase you're typing
another one is having them swipe on a
lock screen and actually taking their
the difference at each point from the
idealized trace path between the Centers
of those targets you might not be
surprised to learn the more drunk you
are the harder that is to do this one's
actually quite cool the balance and
heart rate is such that you hold the
phone with the flash on but you're
covering the camera and we can read the
color of your blood and that turns out
to be a medical property that has a
really long name that I can't remember
it starts with a P I should have put it
on the slide but the color the variance
in the color over time will tell you how
much alcohol is in the blood and we can
read that through that through the
camera when it's illuminated enough by
the flash simple reaction time so goes
to green touch it and then it actually
goes back to red release it and choice
so multiple options okay
so what do we do with that well we had
people go through this process it takes
only about four minutes to run those
first three five times each so a phrase
a swipe and the balance and heart rate
and do that loop five times and then do
simple reaction and choice reaction as
well that whole thing takes about four
minutes and progressively across a week
at five pm that was the start time we
had people come in because we wanted to
normalize for fatigue and other factors
come in and drink screwdrivers until
their breathalyzer measurements got them
showed them at the the right level and
then we know kind of ground truth where
they're at and then we built some random
forest regression models that had a
number of features if you want to see
them all they're in the paper here are
some that that we're important but
essentially they're kind of what you'd
expect you know that times and distances
and errors and things and it turns out
when you combine all of those tasks you
can do pretty well so we were within
point zero zero four percent of the
ground truth breathalyzer measurement
with a standard deviation
Oh point zero zero five percent and the
breathalyzer and our measurements
correlated with about a point nine six
measurement you can see that here on the
left the model predictions and the
actual breathalyzer measurements are
pretty close and if sensitivity is we
say you're drunk and you're actually
drunk and specificity as we say you're
sober and you're actually sober and
that's at the decision boundary of 0.04
then those are our numbers for
sensitivity and specificity so it's kind
of a fun project to explore what's
possible there but the the predictions
are actually you know pretty pretty good
in the end so let's return to these
questions as we wrap up our devices were
more aware
what if our devices were more aware of
our situated abilities how can we make
them so and what could we do with that
so I would say and I hope you will agree
that if we can make them more aware we
can improve interaction through better
user awareness the device being more
aware of the user and we can make them
this way with implicit in most cases so
most of the project three of them are
implicit signals one was explicitly end
their to capture and model human action
and we can do that with walking gripping
attention and intoxication and others as
well but these are the ones we saw and
then what can we do with that well I
hope you'll agree that you saw that we
could improve input models we can enable
new device capabilities we can enhance
user interfaces in some cases and we can
model the users state I think there's a
larger vision at work here I want to end
with because I'm hoping to entice some
of you to pursue a piece of this vision
or see yourself in it imagine a world in
which anyone anywhere at any time can
interact with our computing systems that
are ideally situated to their specific
abilities I sort of sorry ideally suited
to their specific situated abilities and
that our systems do the work to achieve
the fit instead of us doing the work to
accommodate them kind of flip that
burden around I want to acknowledge the
number of people that I've put in bold
here and
others who maybe weren't as directly
involved with these projects but have
been part of my projects for many years
James is there just make sure you see
that and I'll stop there thank you
[Applause]